the new Godzilla anime trilogy has just
wrapped up on Netflix with the release
of Godzilla the planet leader there's a
lot to unpack from the third and final
movie and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film there will of
course be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything in regards
to the trilogy's ending then I highly
suggest that you turn off now for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to unlike most films featuring the
Leviathan Godzilla the planet eater
isn't so straightforward we pick up with
our heroes attempting to integrate with
the who to our culture after the defeat
of Ghidorah they eventually adopt the
tribal dress at the group wear and
discard their weapons allowing for them
to almost seem happy despite their
failure to kill Godzilla of course this
simple life isn't exactly well simple
especially when Martin lazarey discovers
that the nanotech in yukos brain-dead
body could hold the key to reactivating
the mecha suit piloted in the fight over
mecha godzilla city this worries Haru
however who is now pretty much in charge
of the human survivors as he realizes
that with access to this technology
humanity would likely once again come
close to destroying itself he realizes
that humans will be cursed to repeat the
past and with the advanced technology
ultimately create their own destruction
this forces him to destroy all of the
remaining Mechagodzilla technology and
hope that humanity will adopt the new
way of life as this is the only way to
keep the peace using the mecha godzilla
suit he takes Godzilla on face to face
in the hopes that the giant monster will
destroy all traces of the tech this is
where the film takes a rather internal
and psychological turn that may catch
some viewers off God instead of ejecting
Haru doesn't because he fears that the
hatred that he carries could be a weapon
that too ends up destroying humanity the
who - I don't really carry hate in their
heart instead of carrying the philosophy
of that living is winning and that dying
is losing they just accept things the
way that they are and understand that
Godzilla is as much a force of nature as
the tides and wind haru fears at the
hate that
feels inside for Godzilla directly
contradicts his teachings and therefore
he is a danger to his own people just as
much as Godzilla's juxtaposing their
beliefs
Haru realizes that dying is actually
winning and that by letting Godzilla
destroy the technology he is enabling
Godzilla the destroyer of human
civilization to actually be the one that
saves it it's a breathtaking
introspective turn that really shows
just how cerebral and well-thought-out
the film is and is something that I
absolutely loved in the post-credits
scene for the film we see that due to
the actions of Haru who - ah are still
alive and the humans have joined their
tribe we see an effigy of the mecha suit
in which Haru died with children
throwing naught into the burning fire
that surrounds the reminder this
represents that they may be free of fear
for the coming year which also ties into
what Haru did through the fire of
Godzilla he was able to take the fears
of the future and burn them allowing
freedom to continue obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the film and if
he took anything different from it or if
there was something that we missed out
there's a lot to take from the movie and
make sure you let me know in the
comments below if you disagree apologies
if I mispronounced any of the names and
so watch the Japanese release so it's a
bit difficult to translate sometimes if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of what happens when you pick
up the phone twice in Netflix's other
big release Bandersnatch which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who were mega into monsters so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]